maybe there's something about the role
of Martin rakes that leads to trouble
originally introduced in the 1987 buddy
cop movie Lethal Weapon the Green Beret
turned emotionally unbalanced detective
was made famous by Mel Gibson playing
opposite Danny Glover as a
straight-laced Roger Mirta the movie was
a crowd-pleasing hit that spawned three
sequels through the 80s and 90s
eventually finding its way to rebirth as
a TV show on Fox in 2016 claim Crawford
and Damon Wayans stepped into the roles
of Riggs and Murtaugh for the TV series
bringing a chemistry that critics
praised but behind the scenes things
weren't quite so rosy
after weeks of rumored onset tensions
Fox announced that Crawford would not be
returning to lethal weapons third season
replacing him instead with Shawne
Williams Scott it's a remarkable move
for an established series to make here
are the real reasons why it happened
anger management news of lethal weapons
uncertain future first broke in late
April when deadline reported that the
well-performing series was in danger of
cancellation allegedly due to clean
Crawford's onset behavior according to
the report Crawford had gained a
reputation of emotional abuse against
fellow cast and crew contributing to a
hostile work environment that threatened
to single-handedly sink the series the
report also said that Crawford had been
disciplined several times for his
behavior
Crawford addressed the report in a
statement on Instagram confirming that
he had been reprimanded twice during
production according to the actor I
reacted with anger over working
conditions that did not feel safe or
conducive to good work on set safety the
drama came to a head after the
announcement of Crawford's firing which
occurred just before the second season's
final episode in response to questions
and outcry from disappointed fans Damon
Wayans took to Twitter to shed some
light on the onset issues Wayans had set
his account to private in the wake of
the firing then unlocked it to advance
the case against his former co-star
afterwards he deleted his Twitter
presence entirely Williams primary piece
of evidence against Crawford came in the
form of photos and a video taken during
production of an episode that Crawford
not only starred in but directed it
seems that during the filming of a
shootout action sequence Wayans was
struck in the back of the head by
shrapnel from an effect gone awry
tagging his tweets with phrases like
directed by claim Crawford and no
apology Wayans made it clear that he
blamed his co-star for an inadequate
level of safety
placed in charge spill the tea Hawaiians
went on to reveal an alleged history of
misdeeds by Crawford and the anxiety
that the rest of the cast and crew felt
in his presence citing a file of
infractions and appealing to Warner
Brothers entertainment for help wayans
broadened his accusations stating it
wasn't just me he then shared a photo of
a sticker that he claimed other people
had placed around the Warner Brothers
lot emblazoned with the words claim
Crawford is an emotional terrorist
another specific offense cited by Wayans
was a claim that Crawford hit another
actor in the mouth with a bottle of
green tea and busted his mouth open
Wayans tagged the accusation not an
accident Riggs is ready to go just as in
the original film the TV series Martin
Riggs enters the story while grieving
over the loss of his wife and just as in
lethal weapon 2 he eventually discovers
that a drug lord is responsible for her
death and sets out for vengeance the
second season found him bringing the
killer to justice bringing closure to
the characters primary arc if not all of
his neuroses as Crawford explained in an
interview with assignment X we can't
play on the death for four seasons
though he went on to explain that the
show would be planting little seeds as
to the character's future the season
finale ended with the cliffhanger that
had him shot in the chest by his
half-brother with Riggs revenge plot
wrapped up and his life hanging in the
balance
writing Crawford out of the show likely
doesn't present lethal weapons writers
with much of a challenge moving on
perhaps mindful of his growing
reputation for tension
Crawford put on a pleasant if slightly
snarky front in the wake of his firing
as news first broke that Fox was
searching for a replacement he took to
Twitter to share a playfully shrugging
selfie captioned simply hmm he followed
this with a separate tweet reading wait
wait wait you can't fire me on my day
off a more solemn Instagram post
followed in which Crawford expressed
sincere thanks to the fans and
congratulations to the cast and crew on
the show's renewal whatever happens next
for Crawford it seems possible that
lethal weapons days of drama at least
the kind behind the camera may well be
over thanks for watching click the
looper icon to subscribe to our YouTube
channel plus check out all this cool
stuff we know you love to
[Music]